- For almost a century,
it was accepted that
the holes in Swiss cheese
came from carbon dioxide,
produced by the fermentation bacteria
that convert milk to cheese,
and that just sort of...
happened automatically.
That's written in countless articles.
It's what's all over the internet,
and it's almost true.
About 30 years ago, Swiss cheese
makers started to notice that
the holes, the technical term is eyes,
were getting smaller and less frequent,
and scientists wanted to work out why.
Specifically, the scientists
here at Agroscope,
a Swiss government-backed
agricultural research facility,
where, for science, they have
a lot of samples of cheese,
and, more importantly, samples
of the bacteria that make it.
- It's skim milk, and about
one to five billion cells of
lactic acid bacteria per milliliter.
They have a shelf life
of about 10 to 14 days,
so all year round, every week,
the cultures are freshly made
and sent to our customers.
We are a research station.
We have our collection of strains,
but we are also a producer
for these cultures.
We have the genomes of
almost all the bacteria
that we have in the collection here,
and we know what parts of the genome
are responsible for some
effects on the cheese.
- From the beginning of the 20th century,
microbiologists went
to the different dairies
all over Switzerland
and took the cheese
and different products,
like whey or the natural whey cultures,
and isolated bacteria from there.
At that time, each cheese dairy
had its own culture to
produce its own cheese,
and each one of these
cultures was the result of
decades or centuries of
evolution, of selection.
Many of these dairies had to close down
or they switched to the
commercial starter cultures,
and these bacteria that
made up the cultures
would have disappeared if
they hadn't been collected.
So, the collection still expands.
We have around 15,000 isolates.
All of the strains of our collection
are frozen at -80°, and for
the most important ones,
we also freeze-dry them.
Each strain that we store here
has a backup on another site.
- So, each cheese has its
own unique bacterial culture
stored in the archive back there
and regularly produced
in these bioreactors.
The difference between
Emmental and Gruyère
is partly to do with technique,
but it's also the bacteria that make it,
and those bacteria are valuable.
- All the bacteria that we
have here in the collection
are owned by the Swiss dairy industry
to have a competitive advantage.
Our bacteria are not
better than other bacteria,
but they're very regional, very special.
- Some of the cheese types
are legally protected,
and to do that, they have to
use some special bacteria.
We call them marker bacteria,
because they bear a very
specific sequence of DNA
that we are able to detect
in the cheese during the production,
but also at the end of the ripening,
and by detecting this small piece of DNA,
we are able to say, "Okay,
this is the right cheese."
- It turns out that
cheese fraud is a thing.
There's a market for
fake, cheap Swiss cheese,
and in everyday English,
particularly in North America,
there's also no distinction
between Swiss-type cheese
and the specific Swiss cheeses
that are made here near the
Alps, the ones that have
legal protected status
marked on the packaging.
So, Swiss dairies can work
with the researchers here,
they can order the bacterial
cultures, or just get advice,
but it is strictly just for
the industry in Switzerland.
There are trade secrets here
that are guarded carefully,
and which I was not allowed
to even see, let alone film.
- We regularly develop new cultures
together with the cheese industry,
but because you have always to wait
the ripening time for the cheeses,
it takes always several years
to develop a new culture.
- So, a few years ago,
the team here had to answer the question,
why aren't there holes
in the cheese anymore?
- We produce here the cheese,
but then they go down to the cellar.
Most of the cheeses have to age
between 3 months and 12 months.
At several time points, we take samples
to analyze them in the laboratory.
For the analysis of the holes,
we use X-ray and we use
also computer tomography,
so then we really can count the holes,
but we also see the
distribution in the cheese.
- The bacteria that are
responsible for making these holes
produce propionate,
acetate, and carbon dioxide,
and this carbon dioxide
is produced in the cheese
and aggregates all around impurities.
The more the bacterium
produces this carbon dioxide,
it accumulates and builds these holes.
These impurities capture
the carbon dioxide
and then a bubble forms and grows.
- They found that the milk was too clean,
so we didn't have any dust in it,
and this was because we
had closed milking systems
so the dust could not get into the milk.
- Everything improved the last decade.
So, the milking process is
hermetically closed now,
and in former times, in the barn,
you had always this hay dust everywhere,
and it came also into the milk.
- We tried different
particles to put into the milk
to see if the holes are growing again.
Hay powder is the best one,
and we really could see that
the hole formation was dependent on
the concentration of the
hay powder we put in it.
It's only one milligram
per thousand liters.
- Modern food safety standards mean that
milk is far cleaner now than
it ever was in the past,
without the tiny...
well, these days, it's "imperfections".
In the past, it would
have been contaminants,
but, without those, if the
milk is perfectly clean,
the holes just don't form,
and while those holes don't
really affect the taste,
they certainly affect
whether Swiss cheese
looks like Swiss cheese.